we interviewed filmmaker ty West and he
said that you know filmmaking is
actually it can be a very painful
process and he likes to do he says he'll
just lock himself in a room or something
over a weekend and flesh out an idea
because if he didn't he would abandon it
you can find too many holes in it yeah
how is screenwriting for you what's your
process is it easier as you finish the
script
um the process is super complex and it's
evolved over a long period of time of
how to write stuff I definitely agree
with ty that a big part of screenwriting
is is uh forcing yourself to just to
just create and to not and analyze and
to not put it into an intellectual space
I mean my brother even talks into a
dictaphone you know but you know
honestly I think the best piece of
advice and the toughest part about
writing something in my opinion is the
first draft and I called the vomit draft
where you just literally puke up in my
opinion the best thing you can do
yourself is just to write a terrible
first draft that's got to be your
mindset it's like what I'm about to
write is going to be horrible but it's
going to allow me to have a platform to
redo scenes to build it up to give it to
my friends let them read it tell me how
to make it better you know it's just you
have to create the foundation and it's
all about getting it out of your head
and onto a piece of paper because once
it's on a piece of paper now you have
something that exists in the world that
you can share with other people and so
it's a theme that I've been talking
about a lot it's like really getting out
of your head and making the process
getting into the world that's part of
Kickstarter like with Kevin is like
before we went on Kickstarter Kevin and
I were just two guys like wandering
around Austin and Los Angeles and in
Spain you know but once we got people
involved it really helped us coalesce
what we were trying to do because we
were getting feedback from people it's
like wow I love just seeing you guys
together that alone is like really
heartwarming so you know the process of
screenwriting is is is painful and
enormous
and exciting at the same time but the I
just I just suggest you know just get it
on the page and start working on it
do you do that same type of thing that
ty talks about almost locking yourself
in a room for a weekend and just
vomiting out this what you call the
vomit drop just kind of getting it all
out because you saying that you know if
you wait and think about it you know
you're poke holes in it no be like you
know what actually I've come up with a
better idea yeah I don't I don't allow
myself to go back when I'm writing
something I just forced myself to go all
in a row I don't necessarily go away to
do it but when I do write I try to get
it out as fast as possible and I and I
and I don't look back it's so tempting
to do it but if you do that you'll start
rewriting you'll start reanalyzing where
you're going I think it's super
important just to keep going and to
finish it and then you can start
thinking about it and analyzing it
because we've known so many people that
they have all these great ideas myself
included and then they abandon them
because you know what they get bored
with it yeah or I don't know maybe
there's a fear in finishing stuff yeah
um I think it's mostly people just get
bored I get bored of ideas all the time
and you know there's a that's a that's a
tricky point to realize like you know
a lot of people have a lot of ideas
spinning in their head and I think you
know I've only recently come to really
value my own time and like what I'm
going to spend time on it's such a
critical decision which idea you're
going to execute and I think it's also
important not to let ideas sit too long
you know if they sit too long you're
probably going to get bored you're
probably going to have churned it enough
to where you don't need to explore it in
screenplay form or in or in filmmaking
forms you know and what about that
person that has this amazing idea
they're passionate they're in traffic
they can think of nothing else but it
this idea but then it's Apocalypse Now
and it's our first film what do you say
to that person
good luck
I don't know yeah I mean it's hard I'm
not saying that someone can't come out
of the gate and make Apocalypse Now or
make five Easy Pieces or a great great
film but you know it's real hard to make
a 90 minute piece of art that's worth
watching that's my experience is it's
unbelievably hard and when you if you
can boil it down to the simpler elements
of filmmaking you know I mean it's it's
no coincidence that most filmmakers
start with very very simple films and
then they grow in complexity over time
as they as they become more complex and
they learn more about what works and
what doesn't work and what they have to
offer so I wouldn't discourage anybody
from exploring any idea and you can
certainly do it for free in screenplay
form that's the great thing about
screenwriting but you know I think it's
also important to have to have ideas
that are executable at the level that
you're at and that's that's the most
important thing because it's not about
long shots and you know magic and stuff
Leigh it's really just about creating
work that you can share with people so
really have you know maybe have that
passion but have it be tape something
that you know that you can do in one
room yeah or do to you know do your big
200,000 throw in a million dollar movie
and and then you know make sure you have
a small one to that that that a couple
of friends and some five days could make
with a $40,000 Kickstarter campaign
you